number of votes 733 a majority of
members that make up the parliament 374
votes in fair berm 383
roti contrarians 327 one blank vote and
on the basis of these votes the
candidate for the president often
Commission was proposed by the council
and has been elected by the European
Parliament and I would like to
congratulate miss Porsha LaVon delaying
for her election and I wish her all the
very best for her mandate and in line
with article 1 2 4 para 3 of the laser
procedure I will inform the council and
I will invite them for the commissioning
president to propose the various
commissioner positions and there will be
a letter informing them of the
parliaments decision so you're watching
that as it happens it looks like it's
official president the president who is
here
[Applause]
there she is
Germany's current defense minister she
actually leaves the job but tomorrow she
she now is confirmed in her new job as
president of a European Commission of
those numbers against our 133 votes cast
of the Parliament on your election as
president of European Commission on
behalf of the other members and the rest
of this assembly you have a very
important job it's very important for
the European institutions we need to
prepare for the hearings of the
commissioners the designate
commissioners and you know that we will
be very scrupulous in the work that we
do here in the Parliament and you
mentioned topics today here in plenary
and it will look forward to getting into
those in more detail and speaking to the
members of the college with those and
then the competent committees will be
dealing this the next few years haven't
be very important she is important for
the future of the European Union and we
will be successful if there is close
cooperation between the European
institutions I will give you the floor
so that you can speak to the assembly
you have the floor Madame
mr. president and members of this
Parliament I feel so honored and I'm
overwhelmed and I thank you for the
trust you placed in me yet the trust you
placed in me is confidence you placed in
Europe your confidence in a united and
strong Europe from east to west from
south to north your confidence in a
Europe that is ready to fight for the
future rather than fighting against each
other your confidence in a Europe that
will take the big challenges of our
times together the task ahead of us
humbles me it's a big responsibility and
my work starts now
I thank president Cecily I thank all the
group leaders I thank all the members of
parliament who decided to vote for me
today but my message to all of you is
let us work together constructively
because the endeavor is a united a
strong Europe thank you very much
gratzi thank you underlay and now I hand
over letters to the Consul and of course
to president Donegal Donald Tusk and
inform him of the decision that we have
taken so the session is suspended for a
few moments it's official Ursula von der
Leyen a German is a present
Defense Minister that has a new job she
is to be the President of the European
Commission let me just bring you those
figures again 733 of votes cast the
majority that she was striving for was
374 she actually got 383 I gave her
taking her nine over that limit there
were 327 votes against 22 abstentions
and one blank paper watching those
proceedings are with me here in the
studio is DW political correspondent
Simon young and in Strasbourg where that
vote has just taken place we have max
Hoffman Ocilla Fonda lion will will take
up for her position as a au council
president in November let's see if we
can have a word with max Hoffman there
in Strasbourg as a thunder line at
receives the thanks and congratulations
do we have max Hoffman all right that
was I'm sorry I didn't catch their
question if you were actually there and
you are so nine votes a majority that
neither majority what do you what do you
make of those figures
it's a listen there was a learning curve
involved in those numbers last week it
was really all about just getting that
majority for all's enough on the line
that sometimes siedel seemed a little
out of reach so
you know obviously being journalists
there was a bet going on who would be
closest and you had a lot of journalists
that bet for 380 381 382 383 so very
close to that absolute majority she
needed 374 now the optimism in the last
days on the side of also definitely an
increased because the Social Democrats
started coming around you even heard
today some of the green saying they
might vote in favor of her and that's
why many thought you know she might get
over 400 votes just like her predecessor
that jean-claude Juncker the majority
now is is much much smaller than most of
us here would have expected in the late
afternoon and I think I know why this
happened because because of the speech
it was enough on the line that did win
over basically the Social Democrats and
maybe even some of the greens and also
the liberals also alienated parts of the
so-called ECR group which is the
right-wing euros skeptical group where
you for example you have the Polish law
and justice party in there that many
would define as right-wing populist so
they didn't like that they didn't come
up with a consensus whether to vote for
from the lion or not so everybody was
free to vote in favor of her or not and
it appears she lost a lot of votes on
that side of the spectrum
I suppose that she's probably not
unhappy about that given how she acted
in the plenary this morning she's
probably happy that she managed to get a
majority without those parties on the
right
DW political correspondents how many
young reaction to these you know if I'm
on air because that's at your reaction
to it to this result I think is for
LaVon de Lyonne worryingly close it's
single figures close only 9 votes is her
margin of victory I think that does
create a bit of a problem for first of
all it shows how essential these
get-to-know-you sessions and these these
shifts in position that Ursula Fonda
line has been doing over the last week
or so
- you know meet the European Parliament
politicians many of whom have only just
arrived there for the first time after
the recent European election you know
they've got to had to get to know each
other get to know their own positions
work out what goes where suddenly
they're bringing being presented with a
German politician that they hadn't
reckoned with before and she's really
had to work very hard to you know put
put out this message that she's a
listening person who's ready to you know
take on things that are said to her
she's moved as I said earlier very far
really as a conservative politician
towards not just the green agenda which
is perhaps easier for her to do because
that's a mainstream agenda but certainly
towards a sort of left-wing agenda she's
talked about okay you know jobs for
young people that's fine but you know
how do you implement that program how do
you how much money are you willing to
spend on it she's a German in the past
in recent years Germans have not been so
keen to you know open the coffers to get
big social programs like that going
she's also talked today for instance
about a European wide fair minimum wage
again not something that she can
actually deliver but she's apparently
going to you know base as part of her
program on pushing the government's the
member states to introduce something
like that now of course there isn't a
European country where that hasn't
already been discussed the six countries
that don't have a minimum wage you know
a places where you know there hasn't
been a majority for it and their
Parliament's so you know when she said
today you know we need more Europe we
need more coordination more
harmonization more qualified majority
voting and less veto from national
governments on things like tax and
social policy you know this is the the
pro European agenda that has primarily
not been driven forward by you know the
European People's Party particularly
it's at the moment anyway being driven
forward by socialists and greens and
others and don't forget all of this of
course in the
context of the rise of nationalist
parties who you know in some way
threatened to rollback Europe if not
indeed to bring down the whole European
edifice interestingly strangely reppin
is reminiscent of the political
situation here in Germany max Hoffman in
in Strasbourg so Ursula Fonda Lyon now
has the job I think she doesn't start
until November what does she do next
she's gonna give a press conference
later but I think tonight she might
celebrate with a little sparkling water
because that's her way to celebrate an
understanding who knows that because
he's a close confident we can say that
right David McAllister
he's obviously from the European
People's Party so the same party as was
alive on the lion also the head of the
Foreign Affairs Committee and a guest on
DW frequently I saw you hugging those
enough on the line earlier after a
victory how do you feel this was a very
moving moment not only for Salaf
underline but for many including myself
I know as Lafond I now for nearly 20
years we started our political career
together in the regional Parliament of
Neda Saxon and she's just a convincing
European and she's a convinced European
we all knew it would be close we all
knew it would be a hurdle to take which
wouldn't be easy and now we can look
forward there's a lot of work now in
front of us but today coming from the
same region as our fatherland Anita's
accent we are very very happy so tell me
what the people in the EU Commission
have to expect now she's obviously very
disciplined if sparkling water is her
way of celebrating was laFonda lyon is a
very hard-working woman she's very
efficient she's extremely knowledgeable
very bright and she has this ability to
grasp new political issues in depth in a
very short time a huge advantages that
she speaks free European languages
fluently
not only German but also English and
French and she has experience on the
international stage not only at the
European level she also has a defense
secretary she got to know NATO she knows
a lot about transatlantic relations what
does she do have to do now first well
she has to set up a new commissioner she
needs to talk to heads of government she
is announced at the next European
Commission should be gender balanced and
we will then have the hearings in the
European Parliament in September and
October and if things go well we can
start work on the first of November the
new Commission she won with a very small
margin smaller than many today expected
only 9 votes ahead of the absolute
majority of 370 votes she needed what
does this mean going forward for her
work with the European Parliament well
regarding the circumstances of the last
two weeks
I am personally glad that she actually
was elected just imagine she wouldn't
have been elected it would be in a very
dire situation so a majority is a
majority of course this is a close
majority but now she has trust and
confidence of a majority of the VP's and
now we have to talk about content we
have been talking about people